mario está interesado en la relación
entre las horas de estudio invertidas y
el consumo de cafeína de los estudiantes
de su escuela aleatoriamente selecciono
20 estudiantes de su escuela y registro
su consumo de cafeína en miligramos y la
cantidad de tiempo que dedican a
estudiar en una semana dada aquí tenemos
la información registrada en la
computadora del análisis de la regresión
de mínimos cuadrados de su muestra supón
que se satisfacen todas las condiciones
para la inferencia cuál es el intervalo
de confianza del 95% para la pendiente
de la recta de regresión de mínimos
cuadrados si se sienten inspirados pause
en el vídeo y vean si pueden resolverlo
al final lo haremos juntos bueno primero
entendamos qué es lo que está pasando
vamos a visualizar la regresión el eje
horizontal o eje x corresponde al
consumo de cafeína
y el eje vertical es decir el eje que
corresponde al tiempo de estudio en
horas ahora mario seleccionó
aleatoriamente 20 estudiantes y para
cada uno registró la cantidad de cafeína
que consumió junto con la cantidad de
tiempo que estudió y lo gráfico aquí por
lo tanto obtuvo 20 datos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20
ingreso todos estos puntos en la
computadora para poder ajustarlos a una
recta de regresión de mínimos cuadrados
supongamos que la recta de regresión de
mínimos cuadrados se ve así una recta de
regresión de mínimos cuadrados sale de
tratar de minimizar la distancia al
cuadrado entre la recta y todos estos
puntos y esto nos da la información de
esa recta de regresión de mínimos
cuadrados aquí lo más valioso
si realmente queremos entender la recta
lo más valioso es lo que tenemos en esta
columna el coeficiente constante nos
dice cuál es el valor de la ordenada al
origen que en este caso es de 2.544 y el
coeficiente de la cafeína nos lleva a
pensar en que tanto aumenta el tiempo de
estudio por cada incremento de cafeína o
tal vez lo reconozcan como la pendiente
de la recta de la regresión de mínimos
cuadrados entonces esta es la pendiente
y en este caso es igual a cero punto 164
ahora esta información nos dice que
también se ajusta la recta a los datos
tal vez ya estén familiarizados con la
erre cuadrada que se refiere a que tanto
de la varianza en la variable que se
explica por la variable x si esto fuera
1 o 100% esto significa que todo puede
ser explicado sería un buen ajuste pero
si fuera 0 eso significa que no puede
ser explica
y por lo tanto sería un ajuste muy mal
por otro lado s mayúscula es la
desviación estándar de los residuos y es
otra medida de que tanto varían estos
puntos respecto a la recta de regresión
ahora esta columna demostrará que es
útil para resolver la pregunta porque
esto nos dice el error estándar del
coeficiente y el coeficiente estadístico
que realmente nos interesa es la
pendiente de la recta de regresión
mientras que esto nos da el error
estándar de la pendiente de la recta de
regresión podemos ver esto como la
estimación de la desviación estándar de
la distribución muestral de la pendiente
de la recta de regresión recuerden que
en este caso tenemos una muestra de 20
estudiantes y calculamos un estadístico
que es la pendiente de la recta de
regresión cada vez que hagan una muestra
diferente obtendrán una pendiente
diferente y está pendiente es una
estimación de algún parámetro verdadero
en la población
a esto se le llama error estándar de la
pendiente de la recta de regresión de
mínimos cuadrados y finalmente no
tenemos que preocuparnos por estas dos
últimas columnas en el contexto de este
vídeo esto es muy útil cuando suponemos
que no hay ninguna relación entre la
cafeína consumida y el tiempo de estudio
pero cuál es el estadístico t asociado
para la estadística que ya calculamos y
cuál sería la probabilidad de obtener
algo tan extremo como esto o incluso más
extremo suponiendo que no hay asociación
por ejemplo suponiendo que la pendiente
de la recta de regresión es 0 esto nos
dice que si supusiéramos eso la
probabilidad es de aproximadamente 1% y
se refiere a la probabilidad de obtener
estos resultados si realmente no
existiera una relación entre la cafeína
y el tiempo de estudio con todo eso
dicho respondamos la pregunta para
construir un intervalo de confianza al
rey
donde un estadístico tomamos el valor
del estadístico que calculamos de la
muestra que en este caso es 0 punto 164
y después tenemos más o menos el valor
de crítico que lo obtendremos tomando
como referencia el intervalo de
confianza del 95% y los grados de
libertad que los veremos en un momento y
después lo multiplicamos por el error
estándar del estadístico en este caso el
estadístico que nos interesa es la
pendiente y esto es 0 punto 0 57
entonces por cero punto 0 57 y la razón
por la que usamos el valor de crítico en
lugar del valor z crítico es porque
nuestro error estándar del estadístico
es una estimación en realidad no
conocemos la desviación estándar de la
distribución muestra lo último que
necesitamos ahora es conocer el valor de
crítico para eso podemos usar una
calculadora o una
yo usaré una tabla pero también
necesitamos conocer los grados de
libertad bueno cuando hacemos esto con
una pendiente de regresión como en este
caso los grados de libertad corresponden
al número de datos que tengamos -2 así
que en este caso corresponden a 20 menos
2 que es igual a 18 no entraré en muchos
detalles por ahora porque para explicar
por qué restamos 2 necesitaríamos otro
vídeo aquí solamente nos interesa este
valor de los grados de libertad para
poder usar la tabla vamos a ver nos
interesa el nivel de confianza del 95% y
eso equivale a tener una cola de 2.5 por
ciento en cada lado y en este caso
tenemos 18 grados de libertad por lo
tanto nuestro valor de crítico es 2.101
entonces nuestro intervalo de confianza
del 95% será cero punto 164 más o menos
nuestro
valor te critico que es 2.101 por el
error estándar del estadístico es decir
0 punto 0 57 si queremos conocer los
valores exactos podemos usar una
calculadora pero a una forma de
interpretar un intervalo de confianza
del 95% es que el 95% del tiempo que
calculamos un intervalo de confianza del
95% se va atrás la par con el valor
verdadero del parámetro que estamos
estimando nos vemos en otro vídeo